[Musica]
qualche mese fa ho ricevuto un messaggio
che mi invitava appunto partecipare al
The Dex di Barletta e poi seguite una
mail in cui mi si spiegava cosa volesse
dire partecipare a un tedesco ma ancora
niente Non riuscivo ancora bene a
comprendere
il resto mi dicono che sono una boomer e
si sa certe cose le comprendo con calma
e questo anche il motivo per cui vedete
questo leggero qui davanti questa sera
perché anche la memoria incomincia a
essere un pochettino lenta
Poi però ci ho pensato mia figlia a
farmi capire cosa volesse dire
partecipare a un tedesco
ha letto la mail che mi avevano inviato
e già la seconda riga dice questa è la
cosa pazzesca è una cosa bellissima Io
dico sì Carlotta però cosa vuol dire no
guarda è veramente una cosa importante
molto bella però guarda che non è come
le altre volte quando vai a
rappresentare il libro ti fanno le
domande e tu devi rispondere oppure vai
nelle scuole e spiegare ai ai ragazzi la
tua esperienza dice no questa volta ti
devi preparare un monologo ehm
Invece sì guarda vai a vedere i video
degli speaker precedenti Vedrai che sarà
tutto chiaro Ecco io ho fatto questo
grande errore di andare a vedere
questi video e loro da quel momento
proprio dentro di me dentro la mia
pancia si è manifestata pieno il titolo
di questa edizione cioè la tensione
e mi sono però anche chiesta io che cosa
posso dire sulla tensione io l'ho mai
provato l'ho mai sentito dentro di me la
tensione e allora ritorno alle
esperienze passate e alla vita che ho
scelto di fare appunto che mi ha portato
a essere la Marina che qui questa sera
su questo palco ed è vero la tensione Io
la conosco molto molto bene però molte
volte ho fatto finta che non ci fosse
perché ogni volta che si è presentata
Voleva dire che stava arrivando qualcosa
che poteva essere una cosa splendida
come questo evento questa sera o
qualcosa di veramente catastrofico
e allora ho provato a pensare Quando è
stata l'ultima volta prima di questa
volta
che ho provato tensione dentro di me non
sono dovuta andare molto lontano sono
arrivata a febbraio 2022
Quando è stata
dichiarata guerra all'ucraina da parte
della Russia io mi trovavo Lampedusa in
quel momento per il soccorso di migranti
in mare nel Mediterraneo e
quando ho ricevuto questa notizia per me
è stata veramente una botta una botta
che mi ha colpito qui alla bocca dello
stomaco e mi è subito arrivata una
grande nausea anche addosso che mi ha
attraversato tutto il corpo come una
corrente elettrica è arrivata alle gambe
Credetemi veramente le gambe hanno
ceduto per un breve istante di corpo
quel mattino di febbraio tutti noi
europei ci siamo trovati ad affrontare
una cosa che non avrebbe mai immaginato
di dover affrontare a casa nostra cioè
la guerra
Allora ecco la tensione che si fa
davvero forte dentro di me perché
ritorno al 2004
quando ero in Afghanistan e scriveva una
lettera a mia figlia che allora era una
bambina e dicevo Spero che nella tua
vita tu non debba mai vivere un solo
minuscolo istante di ciò che sto vedendo
io qui in questo momento Cioè l'orrore
dell'orrore
bambini con la carne maciullata che
arrivavano in ospedale perché
stavano giocando davanti a casa
trovavano un oggetto pensavano potesse
servire per giocare per un nuovo gioco
lo prendevano in mano e boom esplodevano
in aria oppure
gli altri bambini che nel prato vicino a
casa dove avevano improvvisato un campo
da calcio con una palla che la mamma gli
aveva costruito con degli stracci
sentivano un boato arrivare dall'alto
dal cielo e avevano Giusto il tempo di
alzare gli occhi e venivano colpiti da
una lunga lingua di fuoco
la stessa lingua di fuoco che loro
immaginavano e sentivano raccontare ogni
sera dei loro papà perché raccontavano
le fiabe per farli addormentati
raccontavano le storie di questi draghi
enormi con la lingua di fuoco delle
principesse degli Eroi No questa volta
non era invece una un drago
Ma erano armi chimiche che gli aerei
della coalizione della cosiddetta
missione di pace sparavano sopra
l'Afghanistan nel 2006
e queste bruciano bruciano tanto
Insomma di guerre Io ne ho viste tante
ma Credetemi una giusta non l'ho mai
vista sapete perché perché non esiste
assolutamente
la guerra porta sempre morte paura Tra
le persone i popoli e le nazioni
esattamente come febbraio di quest'anno
proprio come così quando
un attimo prima di quella mattina le
persone convivevano insieme
condividevano una quotidianità
condividevano Gli amori
lavoravano insieme di colpo innalzavano
questo muro di tensione che porta
soltanto olio paura e morte anche la
politica internazionale è cambiata molto
con questa guerra pochi dialoghi per
cercare di trovare delle soluzioni
diplomatiche ma molte parole molti fatti
per inviare delle armi
e poi si innalza il livello della
tensione
internazionale In questo caso ma perché
sapete
Esiste sempre quel qualcuno che ha
l'idea di essere dalla parte giusta più
di quell'altro là e a questi poi si
aggiungono anche tutti quelli bravi a
riempirsi la bocca con formule
antissonanti con distinguo capziosi con
esercizi acrobatici di esportazione
della Pace e con Nobili discorsi armati
anche quando si vuole passare per
sensato il metodo è sempre soltanto uno
inviare armi e potenziare le spese
militari Ma le armi Non parlano mai
uccidono sempre
e così la tensione sale e la paura
stravolge le vite delle persone come è
successo agli ucraini perché questa
volta loro sono uguali a noi Perciò
questa cosa ci ha colpito
particolarmente non sono come quegli
uomini afgani con quei capi coperti
oppure le loro donne con il burqa che
vanno in giro coperte no E non sono
neanche come gli africani che anzi loro
proprio sono completamente diversi da
noi sono neri le persone Insomma invece
no gli ucraini erano uguali a noi ma è
davvero così c'è davvero colpito così
tanto questa cosa
all'inizio sì direi di sì perché
comunque
ci somigliavano tanto ma poi è arrivata
l'estate il covip scende sale non ci
pensiamo assolutamente più e insomma
anche quest'anno mica vorrete che ci
roviniamo le vacanze No per pensare poi
che cosa ad una guerra allora tutte
quelle brutte immagini che vediamo da
mesi che ci propinano in TV soldati
uccisi da entrambe le parti ospedali
bombardati persone che scappano dalle
città distrutte Mettendo dentro delle
valigie improvvisate tutta una vita
intera donne stuprate bambini Ecco tutte
queste cose qui a noi no basta e poi
ancora se pensiamo l'anno scorso
l'Afghanistan l'Afghanistan l'anno
scorso con il suo popolo che veniva
trucidato completamente
e cercava di scappare da che cosa da una
democrazia che abbiamo cercato di
portare a casa loro e non è mai arrivata
e proprio noi che abbiamo portato e
volevamo portare questa democrazia gli
stavamo abbandonandoli stavamo lasciando
lì e poi ancora dobbiamo pensare
a queste persone che invece decidono di
attraversare il Mediterraneo su una
barca su dei barconi sì che insomma ma
che poi ti dice come fanno a stare a
galla queste quei pantaloni qua e
infatti spesso affondano spesso
affondono e ti chiedi Ma allora cosa è
passato per la testa queste persone ma
c'erano veramente cosa pensavano di
essere dei delfini saranno palestrati
avevano i telefonini di ultima
generazione ma anche Ste mamme che si
portano Sti bambini e gli ha preso in
questi viaggi Ma no ma sono tutti matti
Cioè
non possiamo pensare a tutto poi del
resto Cioè abbiamo la nostra vita
dobbiamo fare le vacanze adesso ci
torniamo dalle vacanze però insomma
dobbiamo pensare ad altro Insomma
L'estate sta terminando E vabbè un po'
questi qui diciamocelo se la sono
proprio un po' cercata sta cosa qua
stefini qua che fanno e noi appunto
dobbiamo andare oltre dobbiamo più
pensare a loro e così la guerra ancora
una volta Aspetta nei nostri pensieri e
delle nostre iniziative la mettiamo lì
da parte perciò svaniscono le immagini
brutte di donne uccise di bambini
sfigurati in viso da qualche proiettile
e
non ci interessano più gli uomini
torturati barche capovolte nel nostro
Mediterraneo il nostro mare bellissimo
che ormai è diventato una tomba e non ci
pensiamo neanche più agli occhi persi
nel vuoto elementi spente di donne e
bambini ragazzi stuprati e uccisi nelle
prigioni libiche le famiglie scappate
dalla guerra della Siria
dell'Afghanistan che muoiono di freddo
nei Balcani No non ci interessano più e
allora chi vince la guerra
nessuno mai
Perché da qualsiasi parte la guardi la
guerra è questa cosa qui che a noi
piaccia o no
La guerra è sempre Soltanto questo
cosa che porta morte
distruzione dolore fame povertà malattie
la cancellazione di tutti i diritti e
perciò è giusto che la tensione ci
assalga perché comunque noi questa cosa
qui dobbiamo in qualche modo evitarle
Cosa possiamo fare noi
quante volte ce lo saremo domandati Beh
qualcosa possiamo iniziare a fare per
esempio alziamo l'attenzione quando
entriamo in una cabina con schede e nomi
a dove mettiamo l'X per esempio Ecco
Iniziamo a fare delle scelte che siano
coraggiose ed umane torniamo alla
memoria e poi un'altra cosa facile anche
possiamo farla questo tutti insieme ogni
giorno Secondo me una volta al giorno
può anche bastare ma iniziamo a farla
veramente tutto insieme possiamo dire
veramente a gran voce tutti quanti
[ __ ] a chi ci porta dentro una guerra
e [ __ ] tutte le guerre Grazie